MALE SPEAKER: So welcome back.
We're at Devoxx here with Tim
Bray, who just gave a keynote,
big Google keynote.
And Tim, welcome.
You insisted on the
responsibility of developers
to take care of their own users
on the web because the
web is maybe not such a
safe place after all.
So what are their
responsibilities?
TIM BRAY: Well, there's the
obvious ones that they think
about all the time, about having
a good user experience
and good performance
and so on.
But what I was really worried
about today was more of the
security things because, as I
said, it's a dangerous place.
The most basic security of all
is keep your users' private
stuff private.
And the most basic thing
you can do to achieve
that is to use HTTPS.
HTTPS is there.
It's available.
It's off the shelf.
It's free on the client.
It's cheap on the server.
I think basically people who
don't use it are skating a
little close to the edge.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so how
about passwords?
Is that something you--
you want to say something,
I know.
Password management tools--
should we be using them?
Should people be storing
somebody else's password?
Is it a good business
to be in?
TIM BRAY: Yeah, well, on your
own passwords, I personally
use a product called 1Password,
of which there's
many competitors.
There's LastPass and
KeePass and so on.
And so I have two passwords in
the world that I care about,
my personal Google password,
and my 1Password password.
And that's a good
place to be in.
And I recommend those tools, but
they're kind of high tech
and kind of geeky.
And I don't think non-geeks
are really
going to be wide adapters.
And anyhow, typing a password
in on a mobile device is a
horrible experience.
Nobody should ever
have to do that.
So I think we should try and
stop using passwords as much
as possible.
And to the extent you have
to use passwords, I think
ordinary application developers
just shouldn't do
that because they're hard
to manage, and it's
easy to make a mistake.
And the penalty for making a
mistake and leaking passwords
is really very high.
So if you can possibly
avoid doing
that, I think you should.
MALE SPEAKER: So security's
hard.
It's actually even boring,
I would say.
I mean, other people think
it's exciting.
TIM BRAY: It is hard,
and it's boring.
MALE SPEAKER: It's boring?
So where should people start?
I mean, should they go back to
school and learn math and
cryptography?
TIM BRAY: Well, they should
learn how to turn on HTTPS.
You can do that just by
reading web pages.
That's the first thing.
In terms of actually managing
people's identities, there are
identity providers.
You can go to Facebook.
You can go to Google.
You can go to Twitter.
You can go to AOL,
microsoftlive.com.
There are a lot of people who
will manage the task of doing
passwords and authenticating
people.
And usually hooking them up is
not so terribly difficult.
And I totally recommend
using those.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
Well, anything you want to
add about-- what are the
responsibilities
for developers?
Security is important.
It's not an afterthought.
Obviously, HTTPS is something
you should do.
TIM BRAY: You know, I would
think that, right at the
moment, if you could
do two things.
If you turn on HTTPS and get out
of the password business,
you've gone 80% of
the way there.
Then you can start worrying
about other things.
MALE SPEAKER: And you will be
talking here, and people will
catch you on Parleys about--
you want to say maybe
a word about that.
TIM BRAY: Nicolas Garnier and
I will be doing a session on
OAuth2 and OpenID Connect and
what developers can actually
concretely do right now today
in ordinary web apps, both
JavaScript heavy browser apps
and standard backends like
Rails and Django and Java to
make things more secure.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So if people are really
interested in the technical
side and the security side,
OpenID Connect, and OAuth2
would be the two that people
should look at.
That's the ones we're
investing at Google.
TIM BRAY: Those are the
ones that Google
is betting on, anyhow.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
Well, thank you.
TIM BRAY: Thank you.